gestern war internationaler tag der
pressefreiheit eine gute gelegenheit mal
zu erwähnen dass in der türkei
inzwischen über 150 journalisten im
gefängnis sitzen das ist weltrekord
dafür verleihen wir der türkei die nicht
die goldene kamera die von der
türkischen polizei kaputt geschlagen die
goldene kamera so in der letzten woche
sind wieder 15 mitarbeiter der
cumhuriyet einer der letzten
unabhängigen tageszeitung zu
langjährigen haftstrafen urteilt worden
das sind mutige leute sind noch stärker
geworden
morgen waren wir eine wunderschöne
simuliert wieder übermorgen vision will
nicht bei uns in der redaktion geht
schon das gehäuse los wenn bei der
kaffeemaschine der wassertank leer ist
übrigens gibt es aktuell einen
spendenaufruf für die junior iad
veranstaltet unter anderem vom
bundesverband deutscher zeitungsverleger
einfach mal gucken unter bdzv de leider
ist das thema pressefreiheit in der
türkei ja seit der freilassung von deniz
yücel so ein bisschen aus dem deutschen
fokus geraten
auch bei uns an deutschen türkei
urlaubern die politik des herrn erdogan
stürzt sie aber nicht nein
in diesem falle nicht werde sich bitte
dich engagiert da kann es passieren dass
er ins sogenannte fettnäpfchen tritt
aber ich mache das nicht
wir würden in sogenannte fettnäpfchen
ich will in den pool
ja daran hat gerade den ausnahmezustand
zum ich weiß nicht einmal verlängert und
er hat die wahl in der türkei auf juni
vorgezogen ein cleverer move meine damit
nicht weil ja durch seinen einmarsch in
syrien gerade so eine schöne
patriotische welle rollt jeder der ihn
kritisiert ist ein verräter und lässt
die soldaten im stich er los propaganda
hat wirklich die allerletzten hemmungen
verloren
wir schauen mal was ist ok mädchen was
machst du denn sie hat die türkische
fahne in der tasche wenn sie als
märtyrerin fällt wird sie auch so gott
will damit zugedeckt oder nur mal quer
gedacht das kleine mädchen muss gar
nicht sterben und darf weiter zur schule
gehen
was weiß ich schon mein gott übrigens
hat unsere bundesregierung nach erdogans
einmarsch in afrika in syrien noch 20
rüstungslieferungen an die türkei
genehmigt und das sind nicht alles das
ist ja alles
jetzt kam raus dass man 350 türkischen
ditib imamen im letzten jahr in arbeits
visum für deutschland erteilt hat und
zwar nachdem die tib leute hier
nachweislich erdogan gegner ausspioniert
haben es ist ein ganz klares
machtinstrument diese die tab ein
machtinstrument es sollte hier in einer
ditib moschee in köln chorweiler spielen
türkische jugendliche sterben fürs
vaterland erdogan hat es geschafft ein
klima der angst zu verbreiten das bis
nach deutschland reicht schlimm ja seit
2016 gibt es in der türkei sogar eine
ist jetzt kein witz eine denunziation
hotline
eine denunziation hotline wo sie rund um
die uhr terroristen melden können oder
erdogan kritiker ist ja dasselbe hier
seine aktuell der lieblingssendung im
türkischen fernsehen
so leute jetzt alle rufen so schwer ist
es nicht verräter mit
versuchen menschen mit öl die erdogan
beleidigt haben kommt ihr kennt
irgendwen sonst denkt euch einen aus hey
das ist die gelegenheit euren nachbarn
loszuwerden oder eure ehefrau anrufen
[Applaus]
das ist die realität im detail
man kann
man kann seine meinung dann längst nicht
mehr offen sagen das lernen in der
türkei schon die kleinsten hier das neue
fahrplanbuch alles was erdogan jetzt
noch fehlt für den ultimativen
propaganda triumph ist die
fußball-europameisterschaft 2024 und
sein einziger konkurrent im rennen um
die wm sind tatsächlich vier deutschland
sind die einzigen beiden bewerber hier
philipp lahm unter dfb-präsident beim
pressetermin mit der kanzlerin
dann steht das wollte aus dem
kinderparadies abgeholt werden und die
24/7 leider ein bisschen aus wie ein
hakenkreuz ich saß nur weil mir ist das
egal wer kriegte em 2024 deutschland
gilt als favorit aber von der uefa hört
man die türkei habe durchaus chancen
sebastian pufpaff ist uefa sprecher
hofcafé em in der türkei oder in
deutschland ist doch ein no brenner oder
da ist sie wieder diese teutonische
arroganz zum ersten mal muss ein land
das sich bei uns bei der uefa um gm
bewirbt konkrete fragen zum thema
menschenrechte beantworten außerdem
verlangen wir vom bewerber zitat
maßnahmen gegen korruption
verstehen sie was ich gerade gesagt habe
ein fußballverband hat was gegen
korruption
ich mache mir ja aber hören sie mal
gerade das mit der korruption spricht
doch für deutschland das stimmt das
hatte ich ganz vergessen mein fehler
okay bei den deutschen läuft ja alles
immer super sauber verein never had the
experience personell turm i never never
ever came kamera die somebody to me
something for ever give me die geburt
vor wurde aber er war
[Applaus]
hier war er profi geschichte ist doch
jahre her da kauft man sich einmal eine
wm ist ja auch gar kein vorwurf so läuft
halt ich sage ihnen mal was wir von der
uefa sind total neidisch auf die fifa
die machen super erfahrung mit
diktaturen als gastgeber aber die haben
halt auch viel mehr auswahl
was gibt's ja noch an echten autokratien
in europa weißrussland türkei ok und
bayern
aber das war's also 50.000 verhaftung in
der türkei seit dem putsch versuch ist
doch keine em gastgeber ja nicht optimal
50.000 häftlinge kaufen keine em tickets
mehr
das stimmt andererseits die freuen sich
so schön die türken haben sie das mal
gesehen bei jedem tor gibt sofort
tagelang autokorso ok oder oder panzer
korso durch durch nach syrien
das sind emotionale menschen und
weiterer klarer vorteil für die türkei
der chef spielt selber fußball recep
tayyip erdogan nutzt den fußball der
ehemalige fast profi fußballer der
staatspräsident spielt bei der eröffnung
des stadions selbst mit und macht drei
tore
sony verschafft die merkel nie die
bricht sich schon beim warmlaufen beide
beine und haben sie gesehen hier passt
mal auf die verteidiger hätten alle
schön abstand ja weil sie wissen wenn
ich rein grätsche sehe ich meine familie
nie wieder
wir könnten nicht ernsthaft die em der
türkei geben wir müssen wir müssen lesen
sie mal unseren anforderungskatalog 190
seiten
wir verlangen ein wochenlanges
versammlungsverbot rund um die stadien
absolut verfassungswidrig sagen juristen
das passt doch viel besser zur türkei
wieso wenn es um fußball geht da
scheißen wir auf unsere verfassung haben
wir gar kein problem mit ich weiß nicht
die türkei hat auch so eine schöne
bewerbung eingereicht kennen sie schon
den slogan nein die welt im knast bei
freuen
[Gelächter]
und sie haben leider das schönere
maskottchen maskottchen können deutsche
gar nicht wissen sie noch goalie dieser
grenzdebile löwe mit heraushängender
zunge und ohne hose so ist nicht mal
lothar matthäus in seinen schlimmsten
zeiten ruhen aber auch nein die ganze
welt hat koleos sackkarre gesehen da
lobe ich mir die tür
hier kommt das offizielle maskottchen
der em ticket 20 24 hier ist cody der
verblühte komische mehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da kommt stimmung auf da christoph
lammertz
[Applaus]